hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream number one one one a
palindrome whichever way you look at it
indeed it is indeed here we are here we
are so we're ready you're uh you're back
from uh from covid exile yes
from exile yes that little bit of um
theater last week is is over
um i still have a little
little stuff in my throat you guys will
be noticing that but um but we're good
we might want to just slightly clear up
oh i think we should but let's history
okay we'll we'll get to it yeah i think
i think we should probably start there
but um
uh yeah so we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna talk coven this week because we're
still living this life like all of you
are as well but we hope to talk just a
little bit about some things entirely
not covet as well so we got a little
um south american pre-incan uh culture
stuff to to mention and uh and sperm
whales too and maybe if we get to an ice
fish ice fish did i get that right ice
fish i think it's ice fish i didn't know
you were headed to ice fish no no you
didn't um ice yeah ice fish ice fish
maybe that will give me an excuse to
talk about my ice fishing gloves
will it yes i should i should have had
them here as a prop in fact we could
have done a pro bono ad for the ice
fishing gloves
i don't think we could have because you
don't ice fish no but i do have ice
fishing gloves fair enough but i don't
think that not using them for their
intended purpose satisfies uh will
satisfy them uh actually if
it's a tremendous lesson in how to think
about you know stuff because
whether or not i am violating the ethos
surrounding ice fishing gloves by using
them for things other than ice fishing
i just don't think it would really
satisfy what they if they continue to
market these things as ice fishing
gloves
yeah they do yeah they do but let me
tell you the thing is our audience which
is currently thinking hey we don't ice
fish why are we wasting time on this
they may by the time we get through the
ice fishing glove discussion realize
that they too need a set of ice fishing
gloves for the same reason i do or more
or less not to ice fish no definitely
not yeah
instantly ice fishing presumably refers
very rarely to actual oh hey look what
just got delivered to me by our luscious
15 year old son some nectar of the gods
which is what i call it in my substance
this week this is honey lemon tea
squeeze an entire lemon put it aside put
a large large dollop of excellent honey
in
stir it into
nearly boiling water add the lemon on
top and drink this delightful you should
call it honey lemon chai just to be more
inclusive as i say i should have done
that to the microphone but as i say in
the
in the sub stack it's not tea
it's not it's it's tea by no by no
stretch of the imagination even to the
degree that herbal t might be t
um this isn't t but i don't know what
else to call it other than making it
sound super clinical or weird so but
it's not t nectar of the gods that's
what i now call it it's not t and the
gap between what it is and calling it t
is no bigger than the gap between what
it is and calling it chai it's just the
chai is hipper
it's definitely not chai
right or t true
all right then um
a few logistics to uh to start the hour
um
our our conversation with jordan
peterson came out this week uh in which
we talk about our book um this one a
hundred gatherers guide to the 21st
century and really lovely conversation
really lovely man
the three of us have had very few
opportunities um to talk all together
and only a couple of times in person and
that's pre-covered
but
i believe i'm speaking for all three of
us but i know i'm speaking for the two
of us that we all really enjoy each
other a lot and that conversation was
was terrific so we encourage you to find
that i should hopefully remember to put
that into the
show notes um
if you are watching on youtube you can
find the chat over on odyssey
um
you we encourage you to ask questions
for the second hour
on um
uh for of our q a on
darkhorsesubmissions.com
and both uh that and this our are on
spotify as well right the videos
uh whereas the audio of the um
of the main podcast what we're doing
right now is only on all the other
podcast places uh consider joining us on
our patreons where uh brett this morning
had one of his um one of his monthly
conversations great conversation and i
haven't even had a chance to tell you
that we came up with a plan thank you
yes so good i like with a plan i like
plans generated by smart people who have
no interest in continuing the insanity
into which we are spiraling this is a
good one the world will be rescued in 18
months is our best estimate 24 at the
outside
now i believe that you are to use um our
younger son's
new phrase pulling my goat
um no uh
i'm not quite sure what pulling your
goat would mean but
uh no i we did actually come up with a
plan but it is a very
secretive it's a very hunter gatherers
guide style plan where the idea is not
that we have a plan for um
saving the world it's not a blueprint
it's a it's a trajectory let's get us to
that foothill
yeah so anyway i'm kind of excited about
it it's a very good conversation share
it with me at some point oh of course
absolutely you're central to it oh boy i
mean you're taking all the risk i think
you ought to know what it is
okay yeah no it's good we did have a
great discussion and it did
arrive at something like a plan that i'm
pretty excited about which dark horse
listeners and viewers will be brought
into if they are of of such a mind
i'm sure that some of them are of such a
mind no doubt
um all right uh
so yeah patreons and we do a monthly
private q a on my patreon
as well
you can find various products at our
store zach you can show that one picture
we've got
saddle up the direwolves we ride tonight
we've got epic tabby we've got digital
book burning
as you can see on the screen now we've
got all sorts of good stuff there
uh okay and um excuse me
and of course my uh
my newsletter natural selections uh at
natural selections.substance.com
uh continues to have been about
about coveting stuff this last week um
about you know i called it the omicron
diaries and in it i did
post or actually link to the recipe for
the brisket that i mentioned last week
so you can find that there
and a lot of people were interested in
the very oniony quercetin full brisket
they had a lot of contacts too also
looking for the recipe yeah yeah yeah
i do i think we we discovered that this
really was not what um your grandma
sophie made this is it's a different
recipe um but mostly related um
well
i'll let you and your mother say
something else yeah well
all right
probably she knows better since you know
i was five she did not i did not tell
her anything about you having uh
anything about the recipe i just said
hey what is it uh
brett thinks it's the same
and she then gave us some specifics
about sophie's recipe and i was like
nope not in any way similar so really
well i'm not sure how i got the
misinformation i will say sophie's
recipe and natural waxman's recipe both
excellent yeah um and there's so much
leeway i mean basically that the thing
is if the meat ends up fork tender at
the end then you did it right no matter
what else you got to start with a good
piece of meat it's not a as we said last
week it's not an expensive cut of meat
um but you want to be as high quality as
possible and then you need to take a lot
of time you can't you can't rush brisket
yeah there are there are 16 kinds of
awesome in the universe and this brisket
is nine nine of the kittens yeah so this
is uh this is a long-standing trope in
our household that brett uh when the
boys were very young started to invoke
the 16 cones of awesome and would
announce that various experiences we
were having were three kinds of awesome
occasionally as high as nine that's a
lot
interesting though that he has never to
this day named any of the 16 kinds of
awesome thus protecting himself from
future litigation i expect not to you oh
right and i kept it from the lawyers on
all sides because i don't want our
lawyers abandoning us i don't want other
people's lawyers coming after us so
yeah um but uh but there are 16 and this
recipe if you do it right is nine if you
do it wrong it could be
two or three but yeah it'll still
sustain you
yeah it's life sustaining either way
yeah yeah
and it'll excite your carnivorous they
will be they will be attentive to you as
you long cook the brisket um
[Music]
what else oh this upcoming week on my on
substance on natural selections i'm
hopefully if i get to it
i'm gonna be writing a bit about
uh the different kinds of competition
that men and women engage in because i
just had a piece that i wrote back in
like april of last year
published in the archives of sexual
behavior an invited commentary to
another published piece and that is of
course written in academies
and
a bit arcane as a result because that is
how we are expected to write over in
science space um so as to keep all the
riffraff out and it's not it's the
stated reason but i do think that is
part of the reason so i'm going to
um turn some of that piece into
something a bit more accessible for my
sub stack this week so i ran into
actually a new category of um of some
competition
uh i don't know if you have run into
this um but it's hypoallergenic
masculinity
i i think it's going to be good it's at
least fairly safe
well i was going to say it almost sounds
like the opposite of toxic masculinity
yeah well it's not quite the opposite
but yeah it's definitely at the other
end of the amazing that that with that
venn diagram you the
the intersection of the two groups of
hypoallergenic masculinity and toxic
masculinity is
existent
right i mean yeah yeah i think you can't
go wrong with it yeah i guess that's
that's good okay we have three sponsors
this week for which again we are
grateful for our sponsors very very much
um and here we go
[Music]
our first sponsor this week is brand new
to us and brand new to our doggie as
well our first sponsor is sundays
sundays is dry dog food
when they approached us about being a
sponsor i was dubious we have a labrador
labs will basically eat anything what
possible difference was she going to
show an interest between her usual
kibble a widely available high-end brand
and sundays
i was wrong
maddie loves the food that sunday's mix
seriously loves it and is far better for
her than the standard burnt kibble that
comprises most dried dog food
sundaes is the first and only human
grade air dried dog food no we haven't
tried it combining the we haven't tried
it maddie is eating it but human grade
and yet no the humans have not tried it
i tried it
did you yes oh i thought in light of our
commitment
as advertisers that we could not endorse
this dog food if i had not
tried it what did you think kibble boy
um
you know it's uh
really crunchy it's the best dog food
i've tried let's put it that way okay
great
i gotta change that script then yes
combine
combining the nutrition and taste of all
natural human grade foods
with the ease of a zero prep ready to
eat formula sundaes is an amazing way to
feed your dog and apparently your
husband if it comes to it oh no
this is easy for humans too no fridge no
prep no clean up no gross wet dog food
smells
sundays is gently air dried ready to eat
now artificial binder synthetic
additives or general garbage seriously
look at the label all of sunday's
ingredients are easy to pronounce well
except for quinoa
and healthy for dogs to eat here she
comes
stefan q in a blind taste test sunday's
outperformed leading competitors 40-0
that was done with dogs though not
husbands that sounds like a made-up
number i know but here's the thing when
i have a bowl of maddie's previous food
ready for her she certainly is
enthusiastic again she's a lab and this
is true for all of us we all we all feed
the animals we all take turns but when i
have a bowl of sundaes ready for her
it's a whole different level of
enthusiasm she spins she twirls she
offers to do a little tap dance routine
it's amazing she bounces and spins and
leaps do you want to make your dog happy
with her diet and keep her healthy
try sundays
we've got a special deal for our
listeners receive 35 off your first
order go to sundaysfordogs.com darkhorse
or use code darkhorse at checkout that
is s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s
dot forward slash darkhorse switch to
sundays and feel good about what you're
feeding your dog
you're next man
all right i should say before i move on
to mine i did this does raise a little
story i stepped on something absolutely
terrible in the middle of this week i
was so frightened to look down and see
what i had stepped in
but
it was was it sundays well here's the
thing you said that maddie will eat
anything i had this orange that was
terrible and i didn't want it but i
thought maybe maddie wouldn't i put it
in her bowl apparently she didn't want
it either and she moved it out of her
bowl where i later stepped on it
it was an orange not one of the
decomposing mice that we occasionally
right it wasn't anything super it was
the best possible thing that i could
have stepped on that would have felt
like that
all right
it's a little silly around here it is
okay
glasses
i swear we're not high
it's true you haven't even taken sudafed
which you could totally justify getting
so you're gonna haven't had a drink in i
don't know a week and a half i had
nothing yeah
i also have not had sudafed
okay
second sponsor is relief band
a relief band is a product that can help
you with nausea first though a little
about nausea under ancient circumstances
and some modern ones
nausea was generally a useful signal
that something was off
you had eaten something you shouldn't
have for example
itself a signal or itself a signal that
you should not get near something in
modernity we still need to track our
body sensitivities we should not always
choose to simply erase discomfort like
nausea whenever we feel it that said
some of modernity creates nausea that
does no good at all travel sickness for
instance can be agonizing and relief
would be lovely
travel sickness is basically your mind
registering the jostling of your head as
an indication that you may have eaten
something poisonous which you didn't
so it's a useless signal
enter relief band relief band is an
anti-nausea wristband that has been
clinically proven to relief to relieve
and prevent nausea associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
chemotherapy and more relief band is a
hundred percent drug free and can be
used for as long as you need it
developed over 20 years ago it is the
only over-the-counter wearable device
that has been used in hospitals and
oncology clinics to treat nausea and
vomiting there are zero side effects
now there's relief band sport which is
waterproof features interchangeable
bands and has extended battery life
we asked a friend to try it out here is
her testimonial
i used to have nausea on a nearly daily
basis from both anxiety and the need to
take regular medication relief band
relieves my nausea in less than three
minutes without the side effects i was
experiencing from anti-nausea medication
it has entirely changed my life for the
better
so if you've got nausea from anxiety or
car or sea sickness or something else
you cannot otherwise disable consider
relief ban relief ban makes a great gift
any time of year right now they've got
an exclusive offer just for dark horse
listeners go to reliefband.com and use
the promo code darkhorse to receive 20
percent off plus free shipping and a no
questions asked 30 day money back
guarantee that's
reliefband.com r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d
dot com and use the promo code darkhorse
for 20 off plus free shipping
okay and our final sponsor today is
public goods public goods was one of our
very first sponsors eight months ago
last time uh we talked about public
goods i had a typo in the script that
brett read and suggested that we've been
doing ads for um a year and seven months
at that point but no it's only eight
months ago
and we are as pleased with them now as
when we first tried their products
public goods can simplify your life as a
one-stop shop for everyday essentials
their ingredients are carefully sourced
high quality and affordable
public goods has coffee and tea grains
and oils like olive and avocado they've
got castile soap and trash bags and
essential oils they have spices and
extracts like vanilla and almond
vinegars and pastas dishware and
glassware there is so much of public
goods to make a meal including the
materials to serve it on
public goods products have great design
too the aesthetic is simple and clean
and there are no garish colors
public goods cares about health and
sustainability their products are
largely free of harmful ingredients and
additives and the ingredients are
ethically sourced
finally their subscription service is
efficient and simple and easy to use
public goods members can buy all of
their premium essentials in one place it
really is an everything store
for darkhorse listeners we have the
following offer receive 15 off your
first public goods order with no minimum
purchase they are so confident that you
will absolutely love their products and
come back again and again that they are
giving you fifteen dollars to spend on
your first purchase
go to publicgoods.com darkhorse or use
code darkhorse at checkout that is
p u b l i
o
dot com forward slash dark horse to
receive 15
off your first order you'll regret it
all right
so um did you want to say you want to
start by talking a little bit about what
we were doing last week yeah i think
so sorry it um
if i get one of those kleenexes oh
why certainly
well thank you um
with something very formal around here
i never thought i never thought i was
gonna end up in front of a camera as an
adult much less having to you know
ask for a kleenex for a drippy nose but
anyway here we are it's 2022. there's a
lot you didn't expect there's a lot so
it's a lot i didn't expect so much that
i did not expect
um so yes i got a lot of
feedback on uh last week's episode and
some of it revealed a misunderstanding
that people seemed to have about what we
were doing
that i thought was important to address
because
people were had every right to be
confused by a message that seemed to be
self-contradictory on the one hand we
said that we do not believe in the
guidelines about what one should do
uh with respect to
covid especially in light of omicron the
advice seems preposterous and it doesn't
seem like anybody has considered what
our actual well-being would dictate in
the circumstances and so you and i made
that very clear we made that very
explicit on the other hand
you were quarantining in a different
room
um
and people were like well what's the
deal why are you abiding by
mandates that you don't believe in and i
do not want to fully solve the riddle
but i do want to and i actually i
addressed this also in my sub stack this
last week yes you did and it's well
worth reading and there's lots of other
stuff that you can glean from from your
last sub stack about you know how you
dealt with it and what your experience
was and it's it's well worth reading but
i did want to point out without fully
solving the riddle
we are stuck in a bind right we have two
children in two different schools both
of those schools have
rampant infections as does everywhere
else this is a highly infectious variant
and it is ripping through these schools
and i so far i don't think there's any
indication that anybody in these schools
is desperately ill but people are
definitely
it's not a nothing disease people are
suffering from it and they're required
to to be out after they've when they get
sick they're going to be out for some
amount of time right and they're
required to be out if they've been
exposed to someone who
um who has it and who has not been
isolating right and so the point is we
were living by uh dictates that we don't
believe in not because
we're too timid to resist but because
we're stuck with respect to you know our
children already pay a very high price
for our um
public profile and the fact that we are
not in lockstep with the people who are
claiming to be protecting the public
health we believe they are quite wrong
and in any case
it would be nice if we could limit the
harm to our children uh from
just the simple fact of all of this
nonsense and so living by dick to me you
know i also don't believe that the mask
mandates
that we abide by while rolling our eyes
every time we go into a public building
here in portland where they're required
and where people do abide by it i don't
believe in that stuff either but there's
a level of towing the line that is about
not
uh
inflicting costs on others and frankly
there's also this added aspect of
i don't think the masks work i've looked
at the evidence and i think that cloth
math cloth masks are essentially
a non-entity with respect to
functionality and that even things like
n95 masks if you're not pretty well
schooled in how to use them are probably
a trivial contributor you know not that
this variant is controllable anyway but
so i've heard this before
um we have a box of 95 masks
um
which i've used on airplanes yes um
and i've also heard this thing about
if you use them correctly
it's a really simple object what how how
would one i mean we've all seen people
wearing masks below their noses whatever
like yeah but
is
what what is complicated about what what
does it mean if you use them correctly
um well in part it means paying
attention to the question of how
pressure drives airflow around the mask
versus through the mask
and
basically you know they they come with
this little metal strip that goes over
your nose and you know if you have a
model and it would be even better if we
you know gave people you know if you're
really going to use this to control
something like this you would want
people to stand in front of a thermal
camera or something like that or you
know you could do it with a cold day you
know where you're breathing out a hot
vapor and so you can see your breath
and get used to you know figuring out
how to get the mask to fit so the
majority of what is happening is going
through the mask that's the basic idea
and most of us who use them and i must
say i have long ago abandoned cloth
masks and long ago when i use a mask i
started using m95 mask it's all i use
now
but you know you throw them on you throw
them off and
it's not
you know it is a barrier of some kind it
is much more effective at controlling
something like spittle than it is at
controlling you know aerosolized
particles
but nonetheless it's not you know i can
look at the evidence and i can say you
know what i don't think the evidence a
this variant isn't controllable in the
first place
b the people who are dictating this
proved they you know
they probably couldn't peel a carrot
much less control a variant of this
virus much less this variant that's
actually a great analogy because not
only could they perhaps not peel a
carrot but peeling carrots is
unnecessary yes
right like yeah not only can't you do
this thing that everyone should be able
to do but like you shouldn't even do
that thing
right right but like stir it off and
then eat it right eat it um but the
on the one hand
i do think i'm qualified to look at the
evidence and say it's not strong enough
to be turning the world upside down over
mask mandates or anything else here
but i also recognize
that you know we are all fallible and it
isn't my choice to make for other people
right we can make it for ourselves but
we can't make it for other people yeah
but that is i mean that's that's
actually a very different set of
conversations than um
trying to minimize the already rather
profound harms to our children that they
are experiencing as a result of
extraordinarily bad public policy right
totally agree with this right it is
unforgivable that we are masking
children against this disease without
you know with the sort of log you know
my kid loves these things you know
rather than thinking about the
developmental impacts and all of that no
question about it i'm referring to what
we were doing last week and why we were
doing it so that our children did not
have to stay home from school for a week
because they've been exposed to me oh
yeah i mean i i just don't think we had
a choice we we've got um
we've got regulations and uh
it made sense to abide by them for our
children's well-being and you make of
that which you will
i guess i will say before we move off
this topic um
that
used to be our contacts all the time
and now that uh my close range vision
has has begun to fail rather later than
i was told it was going to but it
certainly has and so i wear i wear
glasses sometimes because i can i have
progressive lenses in these
like everything about me
um
and when i wear my contacts i have to
put reading glasses on and off
and uh to see up close
uh that i can't go out into the world
wearing glasses anymore i would i would
actually be potentially happy to just be
out in the world wearing glasses because
i really like not having to to navigate
multiple pairs of glasses or you know
pull things on and off but i want to
read something
but as everyone who wears glasses knows
masks fog glasses and i've heard that
some people have solutions that i heard
some and they didn't really work for me
but um and so this is this is anecdote
but
bizarrely what i find when i actually
pinch the pinch the nose thing closed
when i have forgotten and going out to
the grocery store or something where my
glass is like oh god now i'm gonna have
to navigate the grocery store
effectively blind because my glasses are
gonna be fogged the whole time
the the way that i wear my mask that
fogs my glasses the least is when it's
sitting the loosest on my face
the loosest
which means that it's doing even less
good to the extent it does any good and
when i've got the nose thing pinched i
feel like it forces it like up around my
cheekbones or something and then my
glasses fog and they stay fogged
so um it's not even clear to me that
this like how you're supposed to wear
the mask thing is uh even doing the
limited sort of good that it is claimed
to be doing well and much if
if the flying of glasses is a decent
proxy for where air is going which it
should be yeah um
even worse you know one of the things
that i think
is so absurd about these mandates you
know we're having kids wear masks all
day at school i mean i you know every
time i i bike with toby to school and i
watch the kids
going to and from wherever they're
coming from wearing their masks like
it's nothing you know they're kids you
bike with him to school without wearing
masks you're not mad
no
we're not masked biking to school um and
you and you claim to love him
yes i do
um but
but
so you see both at the beginning and the
end of school all these kids coming and
going from school yeah and the thing is
they've obviously because they're kids
and they're more adaptable than adults
they've gotten used to it and it's not
abnormal to them and i did there was you
know there was some point at the
beginning of the school year kids were
uh
wearing them religiously and then there
was like a week or two where i started
to see a certain amount of rebellion
against them you know these are kids out
of school
right in the outside world where i don't
even think these mandates apply to them
and you know they were kids like not
really wearing them or wearing it around
one ear or whatever they were doing but
then they sort of seemed to go back to
it i don't know if it was one of these
waves of
fear that was inflicted on them about
new variants or or what it might be well
i've got just the washington post
article for you i was going to save this
for later but this seems apropos zach if
you would show my screen here
we've got washington post
that's not good i have a lot of things
to show on my screen today
i was just making sure they were
connected
okay well
an article that came out
yesterday in wapo in washington post is
headlined it's under the education
section students seeing lax coronavirus
protocols walk out and call in sick to
protest in person classes
wow whoa right
most school systems are determined to
keep school in person but some students
aren't convinced
and then we have a picture of high
schools of a high school sophomore who
helped launch a petition in student sick
out demanding more coronavirus safety
measures or a return to online school in
california's oakland unified school
district
and it goes on and on and on here we
have a quote we were talking about how
we can make school more safe
and this this whole article just strikes
me as
so reminiscent of the safetyism that
we've been seeing since
2013 mass of manos and that
greg lukianov and jonathan hyde discuss
at length in the cuddling of the
american mind
and until now
what the kids have been scared of is
you know racism and sexism and hearing
things that made them scared and
frankly their own shadows and so their
own shadows now includes
literally a variant of a disease that if
they get it now will perhaps make them
immune will certainly make them immune
to it in the future but hopefully to
future variants that may be worse again
like if there's if they're scared enough
of this thing
to to organize to become activists
and petition their school to take them
out of school to keep them safe these
kids are never gonna leave their
bedrooms again
like and you know and this this this was
what we were seeing and this was like a
large part of what a lot of people were
objecting to and worried about about
this generation about both um
millennials and gen z of being scared of
their own shadow and being unable to
take risks and unwilling and not being
able to to see the world as it is and
embrace serendipity but this article
frankly is a perfect indicator that the
the sort of safetyism and then the
like
preformed activism i know what to do
i'll be an activist have just slotted
right in to covet measures yeah it's
it's more than an analogy right it is
it's more it's much more than another
version it is a variant of the same
mental disorder that underlied uh the
woke safetyism
and i would also point out there are
lots of other parallels too right so
it'd be interesting to know
what actually the kids are rebelling
against on the one hand i can you know
we hear a lot of course about the
nonsense that our kids face in school
right the level of it is high
and
i can imagine
that in some sense
you know not
wanting to be exposed to it manifest
says yes i'm not going back to school in
other words there may be a kind of
allergic reaction to nonsense on the
other hand it could be a kind of mirror
of what's going on in the adult world
where kovid disrupted everything people
left their jobs their employers closed
down whatever and then they didn't
really want to go back to work because
they figured out how else to live or
whatever and it just didn't look like an
appealing deal anymore and i think the
thing is
school
is an abomination right it has become
one we have allowed it to become one and
there's no
excuse for this but nonetheless it has
been one for quite some time long before
kovit kovid and wokism have both made it
worse from the point of view of going in
and getting your mind upgraded it's like
you're constantly fighting the malware
installation that is being infused into
every class
and you know as i've said elsewhere i i
sort of feel that the weird connection
between
so-called learning disabilities
and intelligence isn't really about the
learning disabilities at all it's about
the fact that they disrupt a normal
learning process which when it's bad
being disrupted is actually positive
that's right and so
i you know
i wouldn't
i wouldn't rush to judge a rebellion
against going back to school although
the idea of going back to school because
covet is making it unsafe is obviously
preposterous yeah right i mean you know
we just have you know
you can do this in isolation well
there's a dangerous disease circulating
don't you know well yes i do but there's
always a dangerous disease circulating
and this one's less dangerous to kids
than
others that we constantly expose them to
yeah
yeah i mean i just
how do we
hopefully
i hear what you're saying about hoping
that the you know activism against
in-person school is actually activism
against school that's become so toxic
that it's um it's actually harming and
miseducating and
shall we invoke diseducating
um shall we coin that term diseducating
rather than educating um clearly from
this article that's not what at least
these these little activists are doing
this is you know this is safety is a
rona edition and it's it's appalling
and um the fact that
the fact that we're encouraging it the
fact that you know activism itself is
seen as an honorable
educational goal
by many and you know we certainly we saw
this at evergreen there were you know
long before evergreen blew up we saw
certain faculty basically encouraging
activism as the thing that they were
teaching students in fact in fact credit
was given for it sometimes and during
the meltdown there was all sorts of
overt talk about um how they should be
getting credit for turning the college
upside down um and not be penalized for
not doing the work that they were
supposed to be doing right and
um yes
it's
it's not
it's not a sane moment
it's just not a safe moment at all
um well that's where you're wrong now
you're right yeah um do we want to do we
want to move into showing that uh the
brief video
uh from
you know it uh so this is
set up i'm not actually positive um
but um
know the backstory you you sent this to
me and we're gonna have zach show it in
a minute hold on just a second zach
um it's uh it's wolenski it's it's
michelle polinski the head of the cdc
the director of the cdc and tony fauci
the head of the nia idea everyone knows
who fought us at this point
um
testifying before congress i'm just
trying to remember what it was this week
but i don't know exactly what day
uh and um
you know top health officials testify on
omicron response they were called to
congress to testify
and here is some of what they said
possibly can yeah
dr welinski it's been reported by some
virologists and scientists that this
year around 170 people
have died from taking the regular flu
vaccine
the vaccine advisory
adverse reporting system reported that
the number of people dying after or
following the covet vaccine is actually
in the thousands
now this is what i'm hearing
i'll give you a chance to refute that or
confirm it here you know is this true
are we having that many people die
after taking
one of these vaccines senator tuberville
thank you for that question the vaccine
adverse event reporting system is a
mandatory system of any adverse event
that happens after being vaccinated so
if you get hit by a car tragically after
getting vaccinated that gets reported in
the vaccine adverse and voting system
the their system so the vaccines are
incredibly safe they um protect us
against omicron they protect us against
uh delta they protect us against covid
they don't protect us against every
other form of mortality out there do we
keep numbers of people that died
following taking a covet test from
taking this vaccine do we have any idea
i'm just asking
i'm sorry those who have died after
taking following taken the vaccine is
there any number count do we keep
records on that that died of just
uh from absolutely yes i i couldn't give
you then the absolute number off the top
of my head but our staff could
absolutely get back in touch with you we
collect those data you know dr fauci you
have any clue on that about how many
died
100
i don't know the number but i think it's
really important for people microphone
microphone
i'm sorry
i don't have a number but i think part
of the confusion is that when you do a
reporting
if you get vaccinated and you walk out
and get hit by a car
that is considered a debt i mean
that's the thing that gets confusing
that everything that happens after the
vaccination even if you die of something
completely obviously unrelated it's
considered a death so if i had
metastatic cancer got vaccinated and
died two weeks later that's a death that
gets i understand that and every one of
those is adjudicated
so
willenski so just a reminder um
foolishly we can't hear that while it's
playing but we both listened to it
a few times um
wilinsky says quote so if you get hit by
a car tragically after getting
vaccinated that gets reported
okay
even if that's true
that's true
for all of theirs
that's not different for these vaccines
what is being revealed in theirs at the
moment
is that after
covet vaccines
adverse event reports spike
the objection that both willenski and
fauci make
as if they know they're speaking to
completely innumerate and
people who cannot possibly follow logic
is that because you might get hit by a
car after you're vaccinated of course
you're going to see
deaths
that is just as much true after every
single vaccine that has ever been given
and that does not explain the spikes yes
it's also not true um and and we have to
separate these two these are two
different objections to this these
claims that are being made right and the
fact that uh both wilensky and fauci say
the same thing
they are
knowingly lying to congress now
presumably they're not under oath maybe
that would give them pause if they were
but they are
perpetrating a
fiction
on their
interlocutors in congress and the
american public here by saying something
that they both know is exactly wrong
that the vares system is actually very
hard to report into and not mandatory
and what happens is that a small
fraction of actual events get in there
and it isn't things like car accidents
where people know very well there would
be no point in reporting it to that
system because it doesn't carry any
information incidentally also same week
that she acknowledges isn't it that
um that a lot like a majority i believe
and i don't have these numbers i'm about
to ding her for not having numbers but i
don't have the numbers at the top of my
head i believe this the same week that
wilenski said well yeah actually a whole
bunch of the covet hospitalizations are
actually hospitalizations for something
else and then we then they were tested
and then it turns out they also had
covet right so just so that people can
track this
the cdc
does make this error in the other
direction when they are trying to
convince us that mandates are necessary
to control kovid there are all kinds of
shenanigans including involving counting
people who are hospitalized with after
something like a car accident if they
happen to test positive for covid
whether or not they have any symptoms so
that's a game that we have seen played
over you know at least a year right in
order to amp up the coveted numbers they
do count all kinds of nonsense that
obviously doesn't belong there then
they're taking that thing which they
must know that they themselves are using
to make covid look more dangerous than
it is and they pretend that that is
accidentally making the vaccines look
more dangerous than they are which they
know it isn't they know that the veyre
system you know there is not agreement
on how much of an under report i've seen
estimates careful scientific estimates
of how much of an underreported is range
from something like a 99
underestimate that is to say 99
of actual events are never reported to a
90
right
and so they are just simply pretending
and the fact is for most people they
will hear something vague about the fact
that sometimes things are counted as
the result of something that are
actually car accidents that have nothing
to do with covert or vaccines they're
not going to track which place the
accounting error goes in one direction
and which place it goes in the exact
opposite direction yeah and then um
the questioner here who i forgot to
figure out who exactly it is um
is asked okay so you say you can't trust
fairs do you have the numbers then
and she says
um
so he asks is there any number count do
we keep records on that
and she says absolutely yes i couldn't
give you the absolute number off the top
of my head but our staff could
absolutely get back in touch with you
bull [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah lies what are
they talking about why you were called
before the senate to talk about what is
going on with omicron and you have the
numbers and that's the one number that
you didn't bring
well it's it's not like we haven't been
asking for that number because of course
we want those numbers and they either
don't have them or they have them and
they're keeping them from us and we
probably will never know the distinction
but it's one of those two things well
it's one of them i don't think i don't
think it can be that they have the
number because where does it come from
the point is you have a system it's
called theirs we can argue about whether
it's a good system or a bad system
that's the system and what they tell us
is oh that huge number of adverse events
that you see in varus doesn't mean
anything because and then they have a
lot of excuses like anybody can report
anything yeah okay
what that means is that it worse the
verse system contains no information
that's not the same thing as having
information that's saying adverse events
are rare it's like saying we don't have
any information and therefore we're
going to assume they're safe even though
we've got no system we haven't done
looking we haven't asked
so it's
uh you know i i guess the thing is it is
stunning how much theater
there is
in this kind of testimony i was actually
yeah what i was thinking was that fauci
was he's cosplaying the hero again it's
like fake it till you make it man and
you know we we all the whole country was
told that he was
our hero back in
i don't know april of 2020 i guess and
it's amazing how many people not only
bought it then
but still are buying it
well he is very charming
excuse me
i snorted into the microphone
uh that snort was non-editorial though i
think you would be entitled to to you
know snort editorially if you felt like
it um but you know i think the problem
is
he is
so incredibly
charming seeming that people just have a
hard time imagining that he could be
doing anything other than his best he
does a very good impression of a person
who is being flustered under unfair
questioning and
it's
it's preposterous and the problem is oh
did i forget to turn on my mic oh and
simultaneously rip off my mask yeah no i
i must say even that thing you can't you
can't establish anything but there is
something weird about the fact that he
uh
was talking into a mic that was off
while leaving his mask on when his
policy is clearly to take the mask off
when he wants to be heard so there's no
way for us to know what it was he was
saying
can't lip read
in any case he's a uh
let's put it this way the human part of
me sees him
and does feel like
he seems like a nice slightly dweeby
scientist under rotten conditions right
there's some part of me that can't help
but feel
sympathy and then i hear what he says
and i know that he has to know that what
he's saying is
false that it can't be a noble lie
because of what it results in the kind
of harm and uh it's
breathtaking yeah well i don't
that's interesting i think that may um
that may reveal that you're a better
person than i am um but i i cannot
you know when you say things about him
like charming and handsome i think what
are you talking about
like i can't i can't see any of that in
him
well i think it's
uh you think it's just objectively true
no i mean i i i think i think it it
speaks to a different kind of accounting
um you know i i also
basically believe
that um
attractiveness in people
is
uh
a kind of
what is it it is a
summing
kind of
value in other words there is a purely
physical attractiveness thing but the
point is we all know people
who aren't conventionally attractive who
we find
totally compelling right
right we want to spend time we are
literally in some sense attracted to
them right and the point is well what is
that and it has to do with depth of
character it has to do with integrity it
has to do with lots of things which
unfortunately if you don't have a lot of
experience with somebody are partially
fakeable and i think that's what i'm
getting from
fauci is that i think he's actually very
good at it well yeah i mean we said this
last week right we actually think he's
really good at his job yeah
yeah i think he's really good at his job
and we just don't know what it is right
yeah
um
the
oregon health authority
this week or last week
recently
zach can you show my screen
you can
hey look at that the oregon health
authority
is pleased to announce new guidelines
well it's pleased to announce that the
cdc has approved new guidelines for the
madonna booster are you ready
um
effective immediately adults who receive
the moderna vaccine as part of their
primary series only have to wait five
months before getting a booster
only have to wait only have to wait
that's all they have to wait yay that is
the update that i was looking for
because i was just chomping at the bit
waiting for the waiting waiting to be
able to rush out because that is
definitely what everyone wants when they
get a vaccine how soon can i get my next
installment well so if we were you know
as long as we're just idly wishing for
wonderful things then wouldn't it be
great if we had a vaccine that you only
had to wait a week till your next
booster i think so i don't want to have
to wait five months that seems like a
long time in this month waiting is not
fun we all know that waiting is hard
yes
no it's an amazing construction and you
can imagine that whoever came up with
that
you know they really
they earned six months worth of pay for
that
inversion of reality that they have now
perpetrated on the public in which time
they'll have to get two boosters
if they're even getting boosters i mean
i hate to be cynical but
at the oregon health authority i suspect
they are yeah the oregon hell they yeah
we're
yeah remote enough from the centers of
power that they probably are yeah this
is a
low financial incentive outpost out here
yes
um
okay
let's see oh i forgot uh when we were
talking about
that incredible testimony from
wilinsky and fauci
i wanted to point out this piece written
by a friend of ours uh jimmy kim
in her sub stack let's be clear which is
called i was deceived about covet
vaccine safety
she starts by talking about having been
vaccinated
with the modern vaccine in may of 2021
and then this is an incredibly long
article and is incredibly thorough and
first she defines consilience she
basically goes after
the um
she doesn't do this explicitly i think i
did read the whole article this morning
but it's very very long um i don't think
she goes after directly the argument
that um
that uh
uh tri critic trials um randomized
controls control trials i was thinking
critical theory how could you have
forgotten randomized they
critical theory is also the gold
standard yes it is yeah so randomized
control trials being basically the
standard of evidence um
is uh is absurd and really what you're
hoping for is a lot of different kinds
of evidence pointing to the same thing
and you know rcts when done well
um do of course provide an overwhelming
amount of evidence but it's still one
fun signal when designed well and
executed well right and what you're
gonna do there's a lot hiding and done
there right but what they do what
randomized controlled trials do the
reason that there is even a basis for a
claim that they are the gold standard is
that they are very good at isolating
weak effects and making them visible
right by controlling for other all the
other things that might
lead you that might mislead you in this
direction right but i would also point
out that this is a classic
variant on the idea that science is
the
strongest method we had have for
figuring out what is true but it is also
a fragile method it is vulnerable to
things like market forces it is not
robust to them and so randomized
controlled trials are very good at
finding a weak effect in making it
visible
but they are also
fantastically gameable yes that is to
say you can design trials to succeed and
you can design them to fail irrespective
of the thing that is being tested and um
i know it's going to sound like i'm
becoming cynical but the more one digs
and the more one understands about the
way the pharma game is played the more
you realize that this idea that we all
carry that this is the gold standard may
indeed be about the fact that they are
gameable and therefore if you're a you
know a company that wishes to sell
compounds and get them inflicted on
patients then a gameable
mechanism a gameable metric is exactly
what you're looking for right especially
if you're allowed to stop them short
well right the point is look we don't
like it this way we think that medicine
is science and medicine should be
scientific but the point is the idea
that this compound is effective at
limiting the harm of this disease that
is a narrative and the point is that
narrative is founded on what we think of
as evidence but if you have a gameable
kind of evidence then the point is oh i
can link this compound which i just so
happen to have a you know intellectual
property rights to to this disease which
i might broaden the definition of so
that more people appear to have it and
then wow boy a lot of this substance is
going to end up in a lot of those people
and a lot of cash is going to flow in
this other direction and the point is
well
who amongst us really doesn't think that
those kinds of incentives and
opportunities are on the mind of these
corporations who do this yeah
we are all we are all privy uh to
falling prey to incentives all of us and
we all do fall prey to incentives and
pointing out incentives is not the same
thing as pointing out uh possibility of
conspiracy and also
um
those who point out incentives are thus
not inherently engaging in conspiracy
theory so jimmy
lays out her case
again a very long case and one which i
think is eminently shareable with those
who are skeptical of the position
that the vaccines may not be all that
they are cracked up to be if you could
show my screen here zach
um by saying
basically the consilience that that
looking at multiple kinds of data and at
the point that they align concluding
something from them aligning
is a rather excellent way of assessing
vaccine safety here and she says i've
compiled multiple pieces of evidence to
argue that injuries from the code
vaccines are grossly underreported these
include one testimonies from doctors and
nurses two testimonies from the vaccine
injured three evidence from medical
records or official databases of adverse
events four evidence from the vaccine
trials themselves
five plausible mechanisms of action six
evidence from animal studies seven
evidence of past wrongdoing wrongdoing
by pharma eight evidence of corruption
or undue influence in our health
institutions
and bonus explanations for why we are
not hearing about this in the media each
section she continues of this article
could be its own book and indeed
she's got a ton of links in here but um
but it's not it's not even complete as
as will always be the case so i highly
recommend this as as basically a
clearing house of
arguments um and evidence um and
encourage you to share it with people
who say what are you talking about of
course they're safe
so i would just
add to this
um we are all
built
to be logical
not to a fault right there are places
where logic will mislead you because you
don't have enough information so the
logical conclusion you reach is actually
less good than your intuitive conclusion
but we are all built to do logic because
it served our ancestors to deploy that
tool frequently especially when there's
something complex and difficult to
navigate
arrived because then you could you could
at least
try to parse out what was taking place
but this gives you lots of kinds of
checks that you can do on whether
something makes sense right so one check
i often do
is
what would have to be true for this
thing that i think is true to actually
not be right
how like how robust is this piece of
information it's like the mirror image
of a prediction
right it it it's a spot it is a
prediction but it's but it's not it's
like a negative prediction i think the
the the right um
the right analogy is it's a checksum
right you know
if you've gotten a program let's say
you've gotten a security-minded uh
program you've downloaded it from the
internet well how do you know that
somebody didn't give you
a version of the program in which
they've got a backdoor installed and
they just made the website look like the
real website and you downloaded a
program that isn't what you think it is
right well you can do a checksum right
which takes some set of things from
within the program that the originator
of the program uh built that if anybody
modified it wouldn't add to the same
number right and so the point is you can
say well i don't know why the thing i
downloaded doesn't match the thing that
uh the manufacturer is distributing but
i know i don't want to use it because
the checksum didn't match
um so anyway there are lots of things
you can check that way and this is just
kind of a checksum on that a little bit
of a modern modern-day shiverless
it's like a technical yeah it's a it's a
numer numerological which is wrong
because numerology is a weird thing but
it's like it's a numeric it's a numeric
shibboleth yeah and actually
this is this is no i think this is
really good because actually what it is
is um you know so for those of you who
don't know shibboleth is a biblical term
and the shibboleth is a shibboleth
shibboleth is a term that you could
pronounce various different ways but you
could recognize people who really were
part of your group because they would
pronounce it the same way and if they
pronounced it shiboleth or whatever the
alternatives would be you'd know
something was up you're not you're not
of us you're not with us but the thing
about a checksum or and i assume there
are other mechanisms that work like this
the thing about it is there are an
indefinitely large number of ways to be
wrong and only one to be right so it's
like a turbocharged kind of shibboleth
right yeah i mean i think that's true
for shivlas too
chipotles the shibalith you know there's
an indefinite number of ways to to say
it wrong or maybe it's not indefinite
it's not indefinitely oh i see it
it yeah it's more than one i see
there's a plurality uh but it's not
indefinite yeah i see the distinction
exactly
um you were going somewhere
i'm already here
i've been here since the beginning of
the podcast weren't you going somewhere
oh wasn't i going somewhere well i guess
what i was going to say is there are
lots of ways that you can kind of look
at a body of evidence and say does this
look like something somebody might have
constructed for my benefit so i reached
the wrong conclusion or does this look
like the way evidence actually works in
the world where
even if i come at it different ways i
come to the same place because it's
actually true yeah right yeah and that's
so powerful right if i think i know
something
and then i'm working on some other
problem and it leads me right back to
the same
deep truth it's like oh well now i have
two reasons to believe it not one um
yeah something's just canceled yeah
right exactly so it's just a kind of
it's a kind of
uh isn't that that's just so rewarding
it's just like that's that's that's one
of the
that's one of the reasons to do it right
to do this kind of work is to end up
with things canceling and to be returned
back and go ah okay this does fit
absolutely
absolutely and it's a different kind of
reward to be like ah it doesn't fit
these are different things there's an
error somewhere i don't know where it is
yet
but um you know both of those have
reward but
so we were headed to the hereticon
conference in miami we didn't get to go
because of uh because of our encounter
with kovid but nonetheless one of the
things i wanted to do at hereticon which
is going to was going to involve a whole
you know audience full of very smart
people most of whom uh would not have
been deeply steeped in how to think
about uh covid or vaccine safety or
early treatment or anything
the thing i was going to say to them
which i should probably write up or
something
was
um
you
in the public i believe are subject to
an anamorphic illusion
anamorphic illusions are
you've all seen them you just don't know
the word probably like those chalk
drawings on sidewalks that look like a
giant chasm has opened up in the
sidewalk it's extremely compelling it's
very hard to convince your mind you're
not looking into a giant chasm but what
you may or may not realize is that it
looks like that from exactly one
location
right
and so
the exchange that the artist has made is
that from this vantage point i can make
a very compelling rendering of something
with a lot of 3d content you can look at
it from any other direction and then you
get some weirdly distorted thing that
doesn't that makes no sense
right it's incoherent it's at least
stretched and
it doesn't look like a 3d thing it looks
like a crazy thing
and my point to the audience was going
to be you are the subject of an
anamorphic illusion surrounding public
health and the only reason
that that's working is because you're
standing where they expect you yeah and
the point is your vantage point for just
a little right if you step three feet to
your right three feet to your left
you'll begin to see what we're talking
about if you continue to stand there
we're going to sound crazy right right
so in any case i think what jumy is up
to here is a very good indication of
look i believe something that yes you
will be told the public health officials
have ruled out long ago right um
but
doesn't it look like a real object
because it doesn't you know look at all
these kinds of evidence right i might be
able to show you something a picture of
a rock and tell you all about it yeah
and somebody might challenge that it's
not what i say it is but it's different
than being able to hand you a rock and
you can look at it from any angle you
like and
but my you know but
my doctor said that he saw yeah that's
one doctor okay but ten doctors said
that they saw yeah but it's just doctors
okay but these people said that they
were injured okay but it's still just
people talking oh well we got medical
records and and there's oh well but
vares is flawed uh we got the vaccine
trials themselves oh
i don't know what i say about that we
got plausible mechanisms action animal
studies pastor doing by pharma evidence
of corruption she's got so many she's
just laid it out so cleanly all the
different kinds of evidence that we've
got
and um and it's and it's still not
complete right and so the point is what
would have to be true for the analysis
that she presents to just simply be
backwards right
all of these things would need a special
explanation for what had gone wrong and
the point is you can look at
what she says and you can say look i
don't have any ability to evaluate this
kind of evidence i know nothing about it
but then this other kind of evidence i
can evaluate so
maybe the one that i can't evaluate
she's wrong but if she's not wrong about
the one i can evaluate why do they point
in the same direction right so it's it's
that style of how do you how do you
exactly how do you think in a messy
environment that's kind of the thing
which is why you and i always say
welcome to complex systems right yeah it
requires a different style of thought
and you know no surprise she's um i
actually don't know exactly her
background but she's trained as a
biologist yep yeah
so actually maybe this is a good moment
uh to take a brief detour over to uh
peruvian sub-fossil
skulls
okay i mean right i don't know anything
i know you were thinking that i was not
you were not okay i don't i don't have
any idea what's coming all right um
forgive me if i'm disrupting no we're
good okay hey zach do you want to put up
that actually i wanted to show some
street art in dc which is sort of a nice
segue on from anamorphic art although
the street art is definitely not
anamorphic not anamorphic actually it's
metaphorically anamorphic we'll return
to that
okay we're going to return to because i
got some more stuff to say about
anamorphic art too is that can you put
up the uh
the tweet with the peruvian
i did send you a tweet
oh it just came through it just came
through all right
um
we've got it it's happening at the
moment you while we're waiting you can
look at fairfax who is considering some
skullduggery that he might
all right so what we have here
uh
our audience may want to know that uh
there is a
marvelous distinction between fossil and
sub-fossil where sub-fossil is the
actual bones that have not been
re-made molecularly by geological
processes it's actual bone whereas a
fossil from
let's say a tyrannosaurus will be an
actual fossil where what was once a bone
will now be rock that in the shape of
the bone none of the original bone
remains right so what we have here
right yeah none
um right it's yeah it's
molecularly
distinct from the surrounding rock but
um but not bone
okay what we have here
is a sub fossil
uh
prehistorical
and the distinction between history and
pre-history history is anything that
exists after writing so that there could
be a first within a culture so you
actually have um
you know pre-history
in north america
through um you know up and up into the
second millennium uh
by by this very strange and i actually i
don't i don't love this definitely i
really like this definition but even in
north america right with the maya you're
at a different standard i was separating
north america from mesoamerica but yeah
so you you've got you've got one
new world um people who are using
writing in in mesoamerica the maya um
but no one else as far as we know uh was
using writing and so
um you know
they lived rich diverse amazing lives
and had zero and astronomy and
agriculture and you know all of these
things um but without writing they
didn't record
for later generations and later peoples
to see it what it was they were doing
and so we referred to what they were
doing as prehistory pre-history and i
should point out in the case of the maya
um we have precious little of what they
actually did right because the spaniards
destroyed it with the exception of i
think a single manuscript and whatever
was written on temples and things like
this yeah so effectively we've been
bumped back to a level of evidence that
we have with prehistory even with the
maya for the most part right um
but in any case so here you have a uh
sub fossil skull
from prehistory peru
and the fascinating thing here
is that this skull has had a surgical
implant of a metal plate
that has been put in apparently to deal
with a fracture right this person has
received a serious injury but here's the
really amazing part
the injury healed right the plate got
healed into place
and so what we can infer from that
incredible is that first of all it's
incredible 2 000 years ago we had uh
peruvian surgeons doing surgery on a
fractured skull
with a certain
commoner
right but nonetheless or it was exactly
a comedy this was either wildly
experimental okay this guy's gonna die
let's see what we can do or someone who
was very important and they're like do
everything you possibly can
right i mean i just
i'm just guessing that this was not
common practice yeah i don't think it
was but here's the thing somebody knew
enough to be able to do it they used
metal to make a plate to
fit the location and we know that it
healed yeah which means the person
survived it right
so in any case
the reason i raise it
yeah why do you raise it is it is a
marvelous example you know
when i hear that randomized controlled
trials are the
uh gold standard of evidence
and i think well that's all well and
good for you who can have them in some
sense
but right sorry they're fantastically
expensive well fantastically expensive
and us evolutionists we don't have the
luxury of this right the fact is there's
a whole world of evidence
outside of randomized controlled
trials that we actually use and have
made tremendous progress on very
difficult puzzles because even if it
were the gold standard the absence of it
does not render you helpless well but i
mean that's also sorry and i interrupted
you by
by raising this at all but um you know
evolutionary biology is an historical
science and historical science
inherently plays by different rules just
like history the actual study of history
plays by different rules than other
things the humanities because history
happens once and uh you know there there
are not iterations you do not have you
know your sample size is always one
right and so you know you find
you find convergence in which you know
wings evolved once in insects and once
in birds and once in bats and the
wingedness of all of these things is
interesting and you can make you can you
can make adaptive arguments on the basis
of those things having evolved multiple
times but they're not the same
right like flight evolved multiple times
but the way that it evolved the
particular instantiations are different
absolutely but this let's put it this
way people have all we can't do rct's
right it's not an option that's my point
yeah you can't do them and you're not
you know yeah there are things you can't
do well without them very weak effects
that are historical may be lost to
history and you can't you can't
find evidence of them but
we can do a tremendous amount with
evidence outside of randomized
controlled trials for example
you know well that's just an anecdote
yeah that's a 2 000 year old skull with
a metal plate in it and evidence that it
healed after the plate was installed
let's take that argument back just one
one step
i you know
i know that 2000 years ago some people
in peru used uh metallurgy in surgery no
you don't how would you know that i've
seen nothing to that effect
here's here's this that's just an
anecdote and and then and then this
plays forward right so the argument in
this case
that comprises evidence that is not
negotiable well it may or may not but
this is a great test case for what would
have to be
in error in order for this to be an
incorrect conclusion what would have to
be an error
um so i haven't inspected the skull i
don't know anything about the people who
wrote this paper
the skull could be a fraud right if the
skull is what it appears to be if the
skull
was found in the
way that it
is purported to have been found if it is
true that people who can tell the
difference between a healed skull and a
non-healed skull have looked at it and
said yes this skull healed in the
aftermath of whatever this plate the
installation of this plate was
if all of those things are true then
this single anecdotal skull answers the
question was there
surgery being done in the new world
prior to contact with europeans yes was
their red alert right so the point is
you can do a lot with that evidence is
it
incontrovertible no no there are
fraudulent skulls in the history of
science
right them yes people have defrauded and
people have incentives to make
fraudulent skulls right right so yes i'm
not telling you that that thing happened
but what i'm telling you is that you
could rule out the things that actually
make this in any way questionable i have
a feeling that anybody who did would
find that this is a perfectly genuine
skull that says exactly what it appears
to say and that knowing that a plate was
installed and healing occurred after is
sufficient to tell you yeah they did
surgery right they did surgery on skulls
um and people survived it this was not
done on cadavers before mummification or
something like this this was actual
surgery so anyway the point is look
don't buy this garbage about the gold
standard of evidence which then by the
way does not imply the next thing they
want you to believe which is that no
other evidence is any good even if it
was the gold standard even if randomized
control trials were the gold standard it
hardly means that the silver standard
and the bronze standard are insufficient
to do scientific work because they're
not right
and then remind yourself
are they telling you that it's the gold
standard because they're really obsessed
with precision which is what they get
out of those studies or are they telling
you it's the gold standard because it's
the standard they can game and you won't
be able to detect it
yes
so here we have
some
this will come up that's not looking
good
oh no
uh so
this is some street art that someone
took pictures of and there we go
uh in dc today and then um i saw it on
twitter and
within an hour or two i don't remember
what uh reported that he saw some woman
tearing them down
which is you know really unfortunate but
uh here we go we got four pieces of of
street art that showed up in dc
uh for those
listening and not watching we've got
biden holding an uh a mallet and these
are all sort of soviet-style very soviet
soviet art style um
a mallet that says osha on it comply and
he's and he's barking comply comply
uh we have
uh
biden biden yeah that is biden isn't it
uh with needles coming out of his head
and
red masked kids looking up at the sky
and it says good kids are compliant kids
again all of these uh folder uh posters
are soviet art style
um
biden sitting in a chair holding what is
that an artichoke uh is that a
coronavirus i don't know what that is i
think it must be i can't see it from
here very well yeah it's like a
carnovirus that's red and his glasses
are red
um and there's masked people behind him
and it says mandate segregate subjugate
and then finally this is maybe my
favorite
we have father fauci with a halo of
an atomic symbol holding a very large
needle and it says trust the scientism
[Laughter]
so
those are
fabulous
that is what art is supposed to do that
it's not the only thing art is supposed
to do but that is one of the things that
art is supposed to be able to do
and we have a whole lot
i mean this and it's you know it's super
meta of course because it's playing on
actual propaganda and revealing
how
propaganda-ist so much of our modern
messaging is
but you know the fact that within hours
there was someone tearing it down
reveals that this is kind of
metaphorically anamorphic that you can't
see this
as
metapropaganda as commenting on the
propaganda that we are living through
right now unless you're standing in a
particular place you can't see it as
anything but and i'm i'm not going to
play the video that he took of her of
his conversation with her about why she
was tearing them down um but she says
it's bad for public health and you know
this is misinformation and
you know all the usual stuff that if
you've got you know if you've got
if you've got father fauci in your head
and you really think that that's who he
is and he deserves the atomic halo
then um then this is offensive to you
and it feels dangerous
and if you move really not that far just
like not that far
to the left or the right or the front of
the back or you like levitate something
just like move a little bit
and you will see something very very
different
yeah um
i must say i i'm disturbed by how little
art is being used you know as we are
fissioning into
multiple non-overlapping societies the
absence of art at that interface is very
disturbing now i have a little
confession
which is that
i
am very much in favor of this mode
from the other side as well and i
remember as a much younger person
back when evangelism was battling
darwinism
i remember
admiring a kind of both sides of an arms
race
right so you had the jesus fish which
had nothing to do with darwin
particularly but it was a proudly
displayed symbol
and
then
the darwinists
uh put out a jesus fish that said
instead of saying well it was it was
instead of saying jesus in in greek it
said darwin and the fish had legs right
yeah um you know poking fun at the
creationists
and then the creationists came back with
a symbol where it was the jesus fish
eating the darwin fish
and i thought you know i i like both
sides of this i understand we're having
an argument i definitely you know the
fish with the legs
i mean you know this was actually even
before we were at michigan uh when phil
gingrich the paleontologist came back
with his early spectacular finds of
whales with legs yeah right from
pakistan i think yeah and he was there
he was at umc as we were yeah he was so
it was you know he came back and it was
the spectacular news so anyway you know
the idea of fish with legs or whatever
yeah that's
surprisingly on target right it's not
it's not just glib it's actually
sometimes how this works and
um but anyway i like the idea of people
who can be good-natured about their
differences and they you know i sort of
believe that in the end the better art
will win right um you know i don't
believe that for any
deep reason but i think the point is one
side is more vulnerable because its
explanation is worse and so well this
reminds me of something that you've
pointed out often uh which is i i maybe
you're not the first to have pointed out
i've also heard it in other corners but
um you know a movement that doesn't
tolerate laughter or a movement in which
there is no laughter um is not what it
seems and it probably can't last
although
although the the walkery the safetyism
and the woke the walkery seem to be a
mostly laughter free movement and they
they're pretty damn persistent yeah
laughter free and surprisingly tone deaf
including the medically woke very you
know very much more about fear than
laughter you know laughter's probably
dangerous because it spews droplets or
something yeah yeah no
and you know the
no kidding that they want to shut down
comedians right right because the point
is they just don't have they don't have
an argument that can go up against um
being rightly mocked
you know i mean that that's the thing
that's what it's for it's what mockery
is yeah and that's what those posters
are yeah yeah and you know at the same
time i did not before uh before our
stream have time to put together a
list of these things where there's a
bunch of just
jaw-dropping authoritarian moves being
made
in i think in germany i saw that
telegram
is they're contemplating banning
telegram because
people who are skeptical of vaccines are
using it to talk to each other
right now
i am i'm sure they get tired in germany
of being the example of um you know how
could it be them given what they just
what they what they went through the two
generations ago but seriously germany
like how could it be you right
i will say i am old enough to remember
when a move like that could never have
happened in the west two years ago
yeah
um yeah i mean it just it's insane uh
all right okay i wanted to say a couple
things about um
about things that have nothing to do
with coping mm-hmm you ready to move on
or did you want to you didn't want to
introduce anything else well i did have
one thing that doesn't fit with anything
else
you want to save that for the end sure
okay
okay i don't know what it is no you
don't okay by design
okay
oh actually there's one other thing i
don't i don't know but zack tells me i'm
overreacted to this so before we talk
about the the science um
this just pissed me off zach sure was a
man overreacting this is in the new york
times which yes yes i know we still get
the hard copy on sundays um chicken
is broken
this was actually covering the air times
this is a four full page ad that was
actually covered wrapping the new york
times
yeah it doesn't have a date on it
last week chicken is broken
it says
daring
goes on daring
however
um
there's no chicken in this chicken
they actually say
a chicken that's made entirely out of
plants
now
i actually have no problem with this
company i don't even know who it is i'm
not going to say it if i figure it out
like they're trying to make um
plant-based protein that tastes good
even to people who like meat cool that's
fine that's fine
but chicken is entirely out of plants
no just
just know and frankly it feels to me
like this is what postmodernism has
wrought
and it is the ability for advertising
companies and for frankly
terminally degreed humanities professors
and others to make claims in which you
say a is only and shall ever be a except
when it's been
and then just sort of stand back and
watch the world engulf itself in flames
it is part of why we're in this mess
that we're in it's part of how wellensky
and foughty can get away with the [ __ ]
that they get away with well you know if
you get hit by a car after you get
vaccinated against govit that counts as
a vares
covid death or
vaccine deaths like but what about if
you get hit by a car to get vaccinated
against measles
right nothing
so
sorry that may seem totally unrelated
but
chicken is broken okay maybe
um a chicken that's made entirely out of
plants no no it's not well this is
awkward something that tastes like
chicken
maybe i don't know i haven't tasted it
um entirely made of plants okay cool but
stop it with the pretending that
reality a is actually reality b
no
history as we just talked about is is
one-off and chickens and plants aren't
the same thing
i i hate to correct you like the fact
that you've been suffering from a
dangerous synthetic illness which has
probably
robbed you of at least energy
but mental capacity surely i think it's
just distracting you but i mean all
chickens are made out of plants
and we're all
all energy is solar energy yes yes fine
we're in we're all yes
no
i was going to introduce our they were
going to we were going to cut the
gordian knot and we were going to
introduce our audience to the glory of
second order vegetarianism
do it then okay well i mean this is it
you just eat you eat animals that eat
plants and
done right
you don't need this company for that no
no i don't trust that company any
farther than i could throw them but um
but i mean chickens aren't made they
aren't even
made entirely out of plants because
first off they're made of other chicken
from the embryo
and then they're also eating insects
right who ate plants
i mean that's the thing they have sweet
fungus
fungus which ate plants that's the thing
it's glorious
microbes
they did their bread it all looked what
about the autotrophs yeah other
autotrophs beyond plants well all right
that is a minor technicality i saved
them the
the two kingdoms
uh
there are two kingdoms that i think
would argue with you
this is an exception like you know
that's not meat because it's got salt on
it right the
you've got the autotrophs
you've got the autotrophs
actually doing the hard work and
everybody else is stealing it and so
ultimately it all does come from the
answer late to the game as autotrophs
man
yeah but it's what we i'm sure it's most
of chicken feed which i have not tried
but
um
so we're now looking for a new sponsor
right if uh i promise that if someone
comes to us with a chicken feed that
they claim is human grade i will buy us
a chicken so that we can have an excuse
to have it around and see if this guy
will taste it
and you know that i will
as long as it's human grid yes okay um
okay i'll stop talking about chicken now
um
let's see oh here we go um
i i need the link to work okay i'm gonna
have you just briefly show my screen
here for a moment and then zach uh i'm
gonna need it back
uh this isn't this is um not published
in science but this is like their
science news thing um the original
article i will show you shortly
drug-laced beer may have forged ancient
peruvian empire
andean rulers may have fostered
allegiance one feast at a time
the first paragraph being and then again
this is the science this is the report
on the science
in the journal science
between 500 and 1100 ce the highlands of
peru were home to a far-reaching empire
known as the wari
like the inca after them the wari
managed to spread their culture over the
vast distances and rugged terrain of the
andes mountains
now new finds from a small site in peru
suggest that the warri may have forged
political alliances by serving
drug-laced beer to local elites at
periodic parties extending their empire
one trippy feast at a time
so if i may have my screen back for a
moment zach
that was enticing enough that i went um
and read the actual article this was
based on hold on i don't have it up yet
it's different
is it
yeah um
here it is
um published in antiquity
this month the journal antiquity it's
called hallucinogens alcohol and
shifting leadership strategies in the
ancient peruvian andes
at some level who knew yeah like i i
didn't know that this was a realm of
research and i find it fascinating
um
let's see there's one thing at the very
end that i want to share but
um
let me just share the this is sort of
the summary i don't it's not the
abstract exactly but um or maybe it is
in the pre-colombian andes the use of
hallucinogens during the formative
period 900 to 300 bc often supported
exclusionary political strategies
and they later go on to explain that
basically hallucinations tend to be
individual small group if any group at
all and therefore um foster um basically
like they say exclusionary strategies in
which you have either shamans or just
elites doing them
whereas during the late horizon period
a.d
ce 1450 to 1532 inca leaders emphasized
corporate strategies via the mass
consumption of alcohol
corporate strategies via the mass
consumption of alcohol everything in
this is just blowing my mind
using data from from kulkapampa the
authors argue that a shift occurred
during the middle horizon period ad 600
to a thousand when beer made from
skyness mole i don't know um was
combined with a hallucinogen and adenine
there uh colubrina
the resulting psychotropic experience
reinforced the power of the wary state
and represents an intermediate step
between exclusionary and corporate
political strategies this andean example
adds the global catalog documenting the
close relationship between hallucinogens
and social power
and so their basic argument is
alcohol
loosens people up makes people feel like
they're having a shared experience and
anyone can make it right so once you
expose people to alcohol if if if
somehow you have a society where there
is no alcohol which i don't know if that
even exists but um and you and you bring
it to a party or a festival or something
people are going to figure out how to do
it and i mean precisely because it just
happens like alcohol happens
whereas
especially in south america the strong
hallucinogens tend to involve
very carefully curated and crafted
combinations in which you don't just
happen into this stuff right it's not
that you found some some psilocybe you
didn't just find the mushrooms and eat
them and and had a trip they tend to be
um you know very complex recipes
and
that
basically the argument is that the what
they're calling the corporate structure
of the inca and of many modern uh modern
nation states encourages basically
mass
um
mass
lack of sobriety with alcohol
but not the sort of insight of
hallucinogens
because that many people on
hallucinogens wouldn't be controllable
and what the what the worry have done
they're arguing let me find this one
quote that i wanted to share
um
okay there's two quotes actually so
here's one
our paleo-ethno-botanical evidence from
the ware outpost of kulkapamba strongly
suggests that vilca was added to mole
beer at feasts
combining a hallucinogen with alcohol
altered the experience of both
psychoactive substances and we argue
provided wary leaders with a corporate
strategy of governance via patron client
feasting relationships so they go
through the botanicals they actually
have a fascinating list of all the
all the species they found
at this site which includes
quinoa and squashes and cactuses and
cocoa and beans and peanuts and potatoes
and aji
which is a hot pepper and some um
and corn um and then these
solution and this thing they're making
alcohol into um
so we're looking for the
here it is
um
vilka infused mole chicha so chicha is
just the broad name for um the
the alcoholic brew that is still eaten
uh drunk a lot in
quechua territory in the in south
america
vilka infused mole chicha enabled a more
inclusive psychotropic experience in
wari society for perhaps the first time
in the andes the consumption of vilka
therefore moved beyond those spiritual
leaders who commune with the
supernatural realm
the vilca infused brew brought people
together in a shared psychotropic
experience while ensuring the privileged
position of worried leaders within the
social hierarchy as the providers of the
hallucination
people couldn't go source it for
themselves because they didn't know the
recipe yeah so you came to the parties
and you knew you were gonna have
some fun at the parties and you couldn't
go try this at home
um
yeah actually just one more but by tying
their esoteric knowledge of obtaining
and using vilka as an additive to mole
chicha an intoxicant that stimulated
communitas worry leaders were able to
legitimize and maintain their heightened
status these individuals were able to
offer memorable collective psychotropic
feasts but ensure that they could not be
independently replicated
so that's wild yeah i have two
yes so this is
yeah this is this is new to me um one
uh there's there's a delightful little
game you can play where you know
you listen to this description
scientific as it is yep and you know how
would they know well no i
i haven't looked at it but my guess is
you know that's a that's a decently
plausible description of a mechanism and
all of this and who's to say if it's
really 100 accurate but nonetheless
there's nothing about that description
that strikes me as
you know preposterous
but it does strike me as um you know
academics
go to a party and then try to describe
what happened well if they'd written it
while they were on this brew it probably
wouldn't be as coherent right if they
had been invited to the party and it's
easy to understand why academics
wouldn't be um i mean aside from this
being a 1500 year old
practice that's another obstacle
but nonetheless it is funny to me i
think if we were to be able to teleport
to such a party
you might actually be able to recover
their description but that would be like
oh no no that's not that's not what it
was like right you know what it was like
was very well i mean they're not trying
to they're not they're not pretending to
have done ethnography no they're i hope
that they wish that they could right
right that they could have been
participant observers in these feasts
and thus learned even more but
archaeologists are not cultural
anthropologists they do different work
and they have different evidence that
they are looking at which leads me to my
other reaction to this which is
some part of me
desperately wants
alien anthropologists to describe what
has happened in light of kovid and our
public health priesthood and the way
that they have uh gained power and
led the
collected
population into a mass psychosis event
that only served to instantiate their
own blah blah blah deep into the future
would be if you if you had if you could
put
that description uh up next to a proper
and similar description of what is
taking place in the present then you'd
know something indeed yeah no that's
good that is good
um
okay
here oh no it's not coming up hold on
um the other thing and maybe we'll get
to um ice fish as well but
uh here we have a paper
also just published in biology letters
um this is actually from the end of of
oh
looks like it's slightly earlier
actually it's not just just published i
just ran into it
um adaptation of sperm whales to open
boat whalers
rapid social learning on a large scale
question mark
awesome awesome right and so you know
obviously
so they're they're looking at
north pacific north pacific whaling in
the 19th century
and so they're looking at log books
whalers log books so it's indirect that
way and then they're then they're
modeling
and so it's the and the modeling is kind
of a black box i didn't pursue their um
all
of the the data and the models that they
have online
i just read through this article
um where they say we've got all the
explanations online um but they seem to
be doing a really a really compelling
job here let me just share a couple of a
couple of quotes
some historians have suggested that the
success
i'm going to start over
some historians have suggested that the
success rate of open boat whalers and
harpooning sighted whales the second
stage in these whaling operations
dropped substantially during the initial
years of industrial exploitation and
that this was due to socially learned
changes in well behavior
the development of pelagic whaling
operations in the north pacific by
american whalers during the middle 19th
century is well chronicled in digitized
whalers log books so that's the source
of their data
we assessed whether this decline
was caused so um
so
they do see that there are declines in
efficacy which will reduce the effect of
the hot set there it's confounded by
that it's confronted by that but they
actually they actually have four
hypotheses they and again they're using
their model to assess and you know i
don't i don't love the the way that
they've been forced to assess what
they're doing but the fact that they lay
out four alternative hypotheses up front
is such a refreshing change from how
most
so-called scientific papers are written
uh they say we as we assessed whether
this decline was caused by socially
learned changes in the defensive
behavior of the whales that's their
primary hypothesis h hypothesis x they
call it
evaluating support for several
alternative hypotheses using causal
models
the first whalers on a ground were
particularly proficient
that's hypothesis one
the whalers initially captured
especially vulnerable whales hypothesis
too or the whales learn to escape
whalers from their own individual
experience of encountering them
hypothesis three so that's different
from the
their main hypothesis and that's
individually learned like individuals
learn to evade as opposed to their
social learning there's transmission of
social
stuff between groups and in fact it's
even a higher bar than it seems like
they they're asking could groups of
whales have have
have communicated information to other
groups of whales and
they find and without going into the
methods at all
the between unit social learning model
fits the data better than all other
causal models producing a rapid decline
in strike rate as units learn defensive
models uh measures from one another
all right so a number of reactions one
super cool yeah two
um
really skeptical
you've got a bunch of mechanisms and as
far as i can tell none of them are
mutually exclusive so to say one fits
the data better
again i did not spend enough time and i
i just i'm not a fan of the modeling
approach right it was all they had
um so i
but nonetheless they could all be true
and in fact but but they but you know to
to hear them talk about it they find um
it was hardest for them to distinguish
between the social learning model and
the individuals learning model that it
was easier to get rid of the other two
and i think they may it's possible i'm
overlooking it and i apologize to them
if i'm about to suggest that they do
something that they actually did
but there's actually
more
range in here because you could have i
mean in terms of hypotheses yeah yeah so
if you
fans of our book will be familiar with
the style of thought but there are two
ways that you could get a change in
uh
group behavior or lineage behavior that
would result in improvement in the odds
of the whales against the whalers
one is that there's variation between
the whales and how they behave which
there will be and that the
ways of being a whale that made them
vulnerable to the whalers
began to decline because the whalers had
success against them and the ways of
being a whale that
were
incidentally more effective at not being
spotted or not being successfully
pursued then would propagate just by
virtue so that is so that's different
from vulnerable so their use of the term
vulnerable is like old weak young
whatever and you're saying basically
that there will be a selective spread in
a population behaviorally
and some behaviors that weren't putting
them at risk before put them at risk of
whaling and those that part of the of
that behavioral spread will simply be
selected out by whaling right which
won't read as vulnerable because they
don't have the demographic measures and
what and this will you know i don't mean
to diminish it that really is selection
producing adaptation and the nature of
the adaptation is immunity but that's
not social learning right yeah on the
other hand it could be social learning
and there are multiple ways that it
could be social learning there's a
question about
you know again individuals who succeed
and those individuals who succeed then
being let's say even mimicked by other
whales right a successful
well it's you know mimicry sounds like
social learning
well i'm not i'm not discounting that
it's social learning but i'm arguing if
these were humans right you would have
two things uh competing you would have
um humans succeeding at various things
that would propagate and you would have
humans discussing the problem and coming
up with possible solutions right now in
wales we have a highly intelligent you
know these are sperm whales yep we have
a highly intelligent
animal
that does not have language they
communicate but they don't have a
language right so their ability to
propose things to each other is on the
one hand it would seem extremely limited
from the human perspective on the other
hand maybe not right because they can
show right so whale communication might
be a lot more show than tell
but nonetheless maybe although um you
know the long distance vocalization like
long distance vocalizations right but
very short distance what you can see in
water and if you're so close that you
can see it
you're presumably at risk from the same
whalers right exactly but you know i
mean we see we see much smaller tooth
whales like
dolphins
learning special techniques for
you know uh corralling fish and hitting
them with their tails and things like
this
um
from watching but there's no risk to
them in the watching whereas there would
be risk i'm just starting here you've
got a mechanism for the transmission of
information that you know
i don't know if whales can propose
things to each other by showing
but that's a possibility
and so you could get oh you mean later
like right like that was close but watch
this
watch watch what i would do right here's
what i did right exactly so you know
that could be fanciful imagining of what
whales might be doing might be
projecting a human style thought process
on them on the other hand we're talking
about a highly intelligent mammal yeah
and or like oh i did something that
worked i'm gonna i'm gonna practice that
a bunch because that worked and then
others watch it like oh look what he's
doing i wonder if that's what worked
right so in some sense the point is we
argue that consciousness is about
getting ahead of this process so
selection doesn't have to solve the
problem because you can actually
mentally model a problem yeah pool your
insight with others who are mentally
modeling the same problem and come up
with a solution that you didn't have
before that actually works and then you
can try it in the real world and see
whether you had it yeah
whales have some of our tools not all of
our tools and they have them in
different proportions but the point is
it interfaces very closely here with the
question of well how did the whales get
better at this right
um so anyway fascinating stuff
okay um
okay the only thing about ice fish
i've got
is this again it's in current biology
new paper
this one is actually brand new
a vast ice fish breeding colony
discovered in the antarctic in the
antarctic
um
totally surprising there was
oh boy that's not working at all
there it is
um
a
breeding colony of notothinyoid ice fish
neopagitopsis iona probably butchering
that latin a globally unprecedented
extent has been discovered in the
southern wettle sea antarctica the
economy was estimated to cover at least
240 square kilometers
of the eastern flank of the filter
trough trout comprised of fishnets
nests at a density of 0.26 nests per
square meter representing an estimated
total of 60 million active nests an
associated fish biomass of over 60
thousand tons
wow that didn't work at all
um i don't know why it started talking
at me um
well i can't i can't make a computer do
what i want to do at the moment but um
that is massive just that i mean that's
really all i got but
we science western science just
discovered
um an amazing amount of ice fish where
apparently we'd only ever seen you know
one or two nests in a place before and
maybe it's because the entire global
population of ice fish nest right there
but all in one place that's cool and it
you know it speaks to one of the great
things about
being a biologist
at this scale
is that the world is actually full of
things that we've never seen before and
you and i have found stuff that nobody
had ever seen before yeah you know
there's still a lot of it out there um i
just ran across one today where somebody
i think in thailand
um found a
i found this through monica lewinsky who
i saw on twitter
was um uh she said that the person had
uh lost her at the word tarantula um
apparently she's not a fan but anyway
the point is the report that she was
pointing to was of a discovery of a
tarantula a tarantula whose entire
ecology is based around bamboo and
apparently it's the only one
um
what is it doing oh it lives inside the
bamboo and it has a special you know
it's not unlike your your frogs in the
sense that it has developed you know
bamboo is a really weird
uh plant okay but anyway it's cool i
find a little disturbing you too i do
well so i mean
the audience doesn't know that my you
know my research system was indeed
um phytotelling breeding frogs vitamins
just meaning like the holes
that form on in some plants that then
fill with water and then make little
mini ecosystems for organisms that
choose to live in them as soon as it's
bromeliads like we've got the [ __ ]
head back here in the new world it's
dark poison frogs which is the frogs i
started working on
um they
they lay their eggs in the wells and the
bromeliads and then depending on the
species sometimes they leave their
tadpoles
there and mom or dad depending on the
species comes back and feeds them or
sometimes they have their eggs in the
leaf litter and then someone transports
them
um usually a parent
on their back to the anyway
in madagascar the frogs that i worked on
i discovered
a number of things about them including
um that they had a
really really similar system
largely using
um introduced bamboo which is
interesting because there are not that
many
native phytatomic plants in madagascar
there are sort of the troughs left in
big buttress trees
which occasionally i found mantella eggs
and tads in
but very few other things and you know
occasionally in like the what are called
the crotches of trees as well um but
bamboo is the big one so i spent just a
lot of time i like carved windows into
bamboo with taxa and made little windows
with epoxy and ziplock bags and yeah
just spent a lot of time around baboon
if there had been tarantulas also living
in them i would have been much less
pleased with the whole scene that's all
there's nothing a tarantula could do
that would be nearly as terrifying as
what plethodont-hyla natastica does if
you happen to be peering into bamboo
looking for
mantella frogs and eggs
yes that's it is it but they they only
bark
only they don't have a bite yeah but
it's
so this is a frog so heather heather's
system involved frogs that were laying
uh eggs in these basically broken off
bamboo where the water collects in the
rain and but there are other species
that they're just the same i found three
other species that are using the same
thing and this and and a crane fly also
that is parasitizing the frog eggs hole
at some point you're going to have to
explain that's a plain english but
anyway this uh this one frog
um
this one's pieces of this one species
what's the dante la natastica
all right well i botched that no no you
just mumbled slightly
this was the one where the fathers were
uh tending all of the babies in the the
well yeah so the mantella
have long-term um territories and in
fact i identify three different kinds of
territoriality that the males have but
the most successful males the male that
you want to be
defends a territory that has one or more
of these wells in them but there are at
least three other species of frogs
that come in and use these wells for
their reproductive purposes as well but
they don't defend them at all other
moments they just come and defend them
short term including plethodona
highlander tastica which is boy i don't
have the numbers in front of me of
course but i don't know
seven to ten times the mass of a
mentality oh yeah it's a big hand it's a
big honkin frog and they basically the
the dudes fill up the um their their
whole cavity with their with their
bodies and they come in they send out
messages into the universe looking for
sexy female platinum helena toast
because after they get one and she lays
all of her eggs in the well he stays
there and just guards the eggs as they
turn into as they
develop they hatch out into tads
oxygenates the water
the water and um guards them against
predators
until they fully metamorphose and leave
off and go off as froglets and then he
leaves but the way that they defend
their wells so as a hapless photographer
looking for interesting malagasy
phenomena peering into the occasional
well which is of course
very very dark i have a great picture
accident actually that i got of uh
placidanta highland like natastica which
we will show you at some point
hop on pop that's the photo um but in
order to get that photo i had to peer
into these wells and the bark so imagine
a frog you know frog
that size with his head width yeah right
and he's got a megaphone
right but he's got 40 babies bamboo
and his job is that if anything peers
into the thing he needs to scare the
crap out of it so it goes away
and if that something is you looking for
a good photo opportunity wow will that
wake you up man
yeah no the mantella vocalizations are
sweet and you know they can get loud if
there's a lot of them
and the um what is it anadona hilah
antidote hilah blingerize the one of the
other species i don't remember him
vocalizing at all females don't talk
um but plethodonta highlander tastica
man man that is not a frog you want to
tangle with yeah they'll knock you off
your socks yeah exactly if your socks
which because it's madagascar are
rotting
yes
um right i don't know why we're talking
about i don't really either i
okay uh oh we were talking about ice
fish and yes other cool things yeah yeah
that's all i got
all right well i'm gonna leave the ice
fishing gloves discussion for another
time
um okay
i did have one thing that i wanted to do
i had a thought i saw a puzzle i've been
thinking about you know just a topic
that's been on my mind somewhere back
burner for a long time and finally this
week i made a breakthrough and i wanted
to drop it on you you know nothing about
this and i just want to see what you
think oh boy
all right yeah here's the idea
given another
three or four thousand years
of selection under domestication cats
could make great pets
[Laughter]
um
so it wasn't the cats that pulled their
rotting orange out of their bowl and
left it for you to step on
but we did have two
instances of not entirely fresh mice
this week oh there was that there was
there something else that's part of it i
just you know here's the thing i do not
really not do not entirely fresh mice in
the bedroom i should say yeah
squirreled away as it were yeah no it's
not i just
the
you know i do i i understand that there
are people who think that cats make good
pets already and i assume these people
you know he's right here he's listening
these people must
rent all of their stuff right anybody
who owned anything would know that this
is this is not an animal ready for prime
time as a pet but i mean it has a great
promise i think
we invite a little bit of the wild in
yes a little too much and it is it is
marvelous and he is just sleeping
through your
your rant and he will see to it that you
can come up and slater yeah he he's such
an intelligent cat he's been doing this
thing this week um
so we
in order to watch movies at night
we like to put our feet up and we got
some of some soft cubes
that you know are like ottomans and um
which i have dubbed the scratching cubes
right so
he will scratch the ottomans and i will
shout at him
and then he will give me that look with
all of the intelligence in those eyes
like huh you don't
seem to like it when i do that but then
the next thing he does
he will go over to the
cessal scratching post that we have
bought for the purpose of scratching
and he will look me directly in the eye
and then he will scratch it and i can
see the gears turning in his head like
why
are you troubled by my scratching that
but you seem to not be troubled by my
scratching this
seems equal to me
anyway um
he's a smart critter yep
who has very little interest
in your rules because you're not going
to throw him out of his heels are you
no he has the uh the intelligence the
dexterity and the morals of a raccoon
yeah
he does
he does yep and we love him okay um i
think that's
it i think that's it for the week we've
gone on for quite a while
so oh i forgot to mention at the top of
this hour i should have mentioned the
next two weeks we're gonna be at a
different time we're actually gonna come
on fridays um different times each of
the two fridays for various for various
reasons next week we're going to be
friday
pacific time afternoon which means uh
for those of you in europe you probably
miss us
but you know
stuff stays up and we go on we put the
stuff on spotify right away as well at
this point
uh you just can't livestream one spotify
um and then the following we're going to
be coming at you friday morning
so anyway two different two different
time schedules we will we'll be here
just uh rather just a day early friday
morning we should point out maybe two
weeks two weeks from now because
i'm gonna be
no that's next week oh that's next week
oh right oh time yes got it um the 23rd
of january
we are going to
march
on washington peacefully but we are
going to
make clear through our speech
that these mandates are unjustified they
are not justified because the things
being mandated are not acceptably safe
and effective because the people doing
the mandating are not free
of corruption and because it is
un-american
so anyway consider marching with us
january 23rd in dc in dc yeah exactly
um
okay you can use the mandates.com i
believe is the website
defeatthemandates.com
so you can ask questions at
darkhorseadmissions.com
email any logistical questions you have
uh to darkhorsemoderator gmail.com and i
mentioned last week uh that
our moderator can give you an address a
po box to send things to and we have
been getting some just delightful things
from people and we appreciate those
things
um you can of course always join our
patreons we would really love you to
read the book if you don't want to buy
it it's available at many many libraries
many copies
and there's more translation
rights being sold all the time so it's
going to be available in more and more
languages
and anything else to say
i don't think so
all right so be good to the ones you
love
eat good food and get outside be well
everyone
[Music]
you